hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
Live 8 Monate sind seit dem russischen
Überfall auf die gesamte Ukraine bereits
vergangen und viele Staats- und
Regierungschefs waren in der
Zwischenzeit schon da haben ihre
Unterstützung ihre Solidarität zu
gesichert einer hat bislang immer
gefehlt Bundespräsident Frank-Walter
Steinmeier heute ist er in die Ukraine
gereist und hat sich eben gerade heute
Abend auch mit Präsident selenski
getroffen der deutsche Bundespräsident
zu Gast in der Ukraine das ist auch eine
Nachricht wegen eben dieser ganzen
Vorgeschichte weil es auch länger
gedauert hat bis er nun zu Besuch kam im
April wollte er eigentlich schon einmal
in die Ukraine reisen war aber
unerwünscht und letzte Woche wurde eine
Reise die geplant war abgesagt aus
Sicherheitsgründen parallel war der
Schweizer Amtskollege in der Ukraine das
alles hat wie auch noch an die weitere
Vorgeschichte des Bundespräsidenten in
anderen Ämtern hat also dazu geführt
dass darüber immer wieder diskutiert
wurde über seinen verspäteten Besuch
jetzt in der Ukraine und über diesen
jetzt überraschenden und besonderen
Besuch wollen wir heute sprechen und
auch über die Kritik am
Bundespräsidenten und wir haben außerdem
noch in dieser Sendung Zeit mit unserem
Gesprächspartner der öfter bei uns zu
Gast ist mit ex-nato General Egon Rams
über die aktuelle Lage militärische Lage
im Land zu sprechen schauen wir aber
zuerst auf den Tag auf den Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten und ein eine
Zusammenfassung von Lena sünderbruch
es ist der 9 Monat seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffs aber der erste
Besuch von Bundespräsident Steinmeier in
dieser Zeit es sei ein Zeichen der
Solidarität in der Phase der
niederträchtigen russischen Luftangriffe
im ganzen Land sagte am Morgen in Kiel
meine Botschaft an die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer ist wir stehen nicht nur an
eurer Seite sondern wir werden die
Ukraine auch weiterhin unterstützen
wirtschaftlich politisch und auch
militärisch in der Kleinstadt im Norden
des Landes zeigt sich eindrücklich was
der Krieg dort für die Menschen bedeutet
Luftalarm zwingt den Bundespräsidenten
seine Begegnungen mit den Einwohnern in
einen Luftschutzkeller zu verlegen
kojukivka sei ein Ort in dem die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger viel Mut bewiesen
haben die sich mit bloßen Händen den
Panzern entgegengestellt haben und sie
tatsächlich
zum Stoppen gebracht haben Gespräche mit
Bürgern wie auch hier in einer
Brotfabrik kommen heute in der Ukraine
erst im dritten Anlauf Zustande nun
demonstriert Steinmeier bei einem
Rundgang durch Kiew mit Bürgermeister
Klitschko die Ukraine kann sich auf
Deutschland verlassen das soll auch bei
einem Gespräch mit Präsident selenski
deutlich werden
ihr könnt natürlich Fragen stellen
Kommentare schreiben und jetzt direkt
fangen wir nämlich an eure Fragen an
Nicole Diekmann unsere Korrespondentin
im Hauptstadtstudio heute auch wieder
bei uns zu Gast schönen guten Abend
Nicole hallo
Nicole diese Reise diese besondere Reise
jetzt auch tatsächlich heute
überraschende Reise war ja länger
geplant fand aber ich habe es
angesprochen auch lange Monate einfach
gar nicht statt warum ist der erst jetzt
gekommen Frank Walter Steinmeier tja
Versuch Nummer eins das war im April da
wurde Steinmeier mehr oder weniger
ausgeladen von Kiew aus da gab es große
Verstimmungen das hatte dann auch noch
weitere folgen nämlich dass der Kanzler
Olaf Scholz erstmal auch nicht nach Kiew
gereist ist weil er gesagt hat ich kann
mich mich darüber hinwegsetzen dass der
oberste repräsentante startet der
Bundespräsident nicht kommen darf und
ich fahre dann das
Gebiete der Anstand dass ich das nicht
tue und dann gab es letzte Woche den
zweiten Versuch von Frank-Walter
Steinmeier nach Kiew zu reisen da gab es
dann Sicherheitsbedenken unter anderem
vom BKA das führte dann hierzulande zu
Kritik weil
andere Politiker der Schweizer zum
Beispiel dann trotzdem nach Kiew gereist
sind nun aber für uns alle sehr
überraschend ist Frank-Walter Steinmeier
dann gestern in die Ukraine gereist und
er hat sich soeben mit Präsident
selenski getroffen wir haben die
Statements der beiden auch nun vorliegen
und hören zuerst in das Statement des
ukrainischen Präsidenten von selensky
rein
Beitrag der Bundesrepublik
zum Frieden in der Ukraine zum wird auch
aufbaut so der rituellen interkretet ist
groß und historisch wichtig heute haben
wir mit Herren Präsidentin Verhandlungen
geführt diese entsprechenden Beziehungen
zwischen unseren Staaten ich danke
Deutschland für die Gewährung für die
Lieferung des
luftabwehrsystems arestie das System hat
sich bereits gut gezeigt beim Schutz
unseres Himmels bei der Rettung unserer
Menschen das ist wirklich eine Priorität
für uns wir spüren das und ich hoffe
dass in der nächsten Zeit wie auch
weitere Systeme dieser Art bekommen
können ich eine Firma informierte Herr
Präsidenten Steinmeier über andere
verteidigungsbedürfnis unseres Landes
die auch prioritäre sind für den Schutz
der Ukraine und für die Befreiung
unseres Landes unter anderem betrifft
das auch Systeme der erzählerie
gepanzert der Technik und andere
erwarten wir besprachen das ganze
Spektrum der Gefahren die durch Russland
geschaffen wurden in dieser Phase des
Angriffskrieges
sie sprachen über Gefahren sagt der
ukrainische Präsident auch der
Bundespräsident saß heute direkt am
Anfang seines Besuchs anderthalb Stunden
erstmal im Luftschutzkeller nach dem
Alarm der ausgelöst wurde wie so häufig
in der Ukraine in diesen Tagen und so
begann also der Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten der sich auch heute
Abend in einem Statement geäußert hat
und wir hören jetzt auch hier zusammen
rein gerade jetzt im Angesicht der
niederträchtigen russischen Angriffe mit
Raketen und Drohnen auf Infrastrukturen
im ganzen Land war es mir wichtig
hierher zu kommen und den Menschen in
der Ukraine
natürlich hier in der Hauptstadt aber
auch jenseits der Hauptstadt in den
Dörfern und Städten zu sagen wir sind
auf eurer Seite wir unterstützen euch
wir werden euch weiter unterstützen
wirtschaftlich politisch militärisch
solange wie nötig
seit acht Monaten meine Damen und Herren
führt Russland ein brutalen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg gegen
Irland herr Präsident einen Krieg der
europa-sicherheit in Trümmer gelegt hat
und der die Menschen in ganz Europa auch
in Deutschland wirklich im Innersten
trifft und bewegt
heute war ich dankbar herr Präsident
dass ich einen ganzen Tag lang durch die
Augen der Ukraine auf die Lage im Krieg
blicken konnte und ich konnte mit vielen
sprechen
vieles sehen kann am Ende dieses Tages
sagen ich bin wirklich voller
aufrichtiger Bewunderung für den Mut
für die
Unbeugsamkeit den Freiheitswillen und
die Tapferkeit der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine
wir sind auf eurer Seite sagte der
Bundespräsident und unterstützen so
lange wie möglich Nicole der Zweck und
das Ziel jetzt des Besuchs des
Bundespräsidenten wie ist das
einzuschätzen ging es da jetzt auch ganz
klar eben um das Zeichen von Solidarität
ging es da um mehr ging es da vielleicht
sogar auch um mehr noch zu sagen für
Hilfen für Waffenlieferungen was ist
Zweck und Ziel des Besuchs heute gewesen
dieser Besuch hat mehrere Zwecke und
mehrere Ziele wir haben es gerade gehört
natürlich ist vordergründig es ist ja
ein Symbol wenn der Bundespräsident nach
Kiew in die Ukraine reist der ist kein
Regierungschef sondern er repräsentiert
Deutschland man ist ja sehr spät gereist
aber man kann sagen besser spät als
nehmen das heißt das ist natürlich auch
ein Symbol das großes Interesse
Deutschlands herrscht an einem guten
Verhältnis zu Ukraine das könnte man als
selbstverständlich sehen aber
zweiter Zweck Frank-Walter Steinmeier
war ja nicht immer Bundespräsident und
der war ja nicht niemand bevor er
bundespräsiden vor der Sonnabend
Frank-Walter Steinmeier war unter
anderem Außenminister und zwar zweimal
und Frank Walter Steinmeier ist
SPD-Politiker vergangene Woche hat der
derzeitige SPD-Chef Lars Klingbeil
ziemlich offen Fehler in der
Vergangenheit der SPD im Umgang mit
Russland also dem Staat der die Ukraine
überfallen hat eingeräumt und wegen
dieser Politik die Frank-Walter
Steinmeier eben als Außenminister aber
auch als Kanzleramtsminister unter
Gerhard Schröder mitzuverantworten hatte
diese Kritik hat natürlich auch Frank
Walter Steinmeier in den letzten Monaten
getroffen es gibt Bilder die ihn mit dem
russischen Außenminister sergeyla France
in sehr freundschaftlicher Geste zeigen
und auch das ist natürlich heute ein
Signal das von diesen Besuch ausgehen
soll ich habe verstanden der nächste
Punkt ist Frank-Walter Steinmeier steht
besonders jetzt in seiner zweiten
Amtszeit als Bundespräsident immer mehr
in der Kritik in den vergangene Woche
war es glaube ich da erschien ein
Zeitungsartikel über ihn ein Porträt mit
dem vielsagenden Titel der falsche Mann
im höchsten Staatsamt die Kritiker sagen
es fehlt die große Geste es fehlt die
große Rede gerade in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten und auch das ist natürlich ein
Signal von dem Frank-Walter Steinmeier
sich erhofft dass es von dieser Reise
ausgeht dass er verstanden hat dass er
Signale senden muss du hast die Kritik
angesprochen die Kritik der Ukraine an
am Bundespräsidenten und wir haben einen
Rückblick ein Stück vorbereitet von
Laura Rosinus wo wir jetzt zusammen auch
noch mal zurückschauen können und danach
noch weitere Fragen beantworten
kaum ein anderer aktiver Politiker steht
so sehr für die deutsche
russland-politik wie Frank Walter
Steinmeier als Kanzleramtsminister unter
Gerhard Schröder und Außenminister unter
Angela Merkel trug er sie mit die
freundschaftliche und auch
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
ausgelegte Russlandpolitik der
Bundesregierung und er prägte sie
bei seinem Besuch 2005 als Außenminister
in Moskau ging es auch um meine
Ostsee-Pipeline von Russland nach
Deutschland die später unter dem Namen
Nord Stream bekannt werden würde
2014 dann viel Putin erstmals in der
Ukraine ein und annektierte die Krim ein
Jahr darauf gab Steinmeier als
Außenminister dennoch seinen Segen für
eine weitere Pipeline nämlich Nord
Stream 2 dieses Projekt verteidigte er
noch bis kurz vor Beginn des
Angriffskrieges erst danach räumt er im
ZDF Fehler ein
wir sind gescheitert mit dem Bemühen
Russland einzubinden in eine europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur wir sind
gescheitert mit dem Bemühen der Kader
von Paris
auch Russland mitzunehmen auf dem Weg
Richtung Demokratie und Menschenrechten
das ist eine bittere Bilanz vor der wir
stehen eine Reise nach Kiew plante
Steinmeier dann mit April gemeinsam mit
den Präsidenten aus Polen und den drei
baltischen Staaten doch dazu kam es
nicht die ukrainische Regierung lehnte
ab der Grund wegen seiner
russlandfreundlichen Politik der
vergangenen Jahre sei er anders als die
anderen Präsidenten nicht willkommen ich
war dazu bereit
aber offenbar und ich muss zur Kenntnis
nehmen war das in Kiew nicht gewünscht
der damalige ukrainische Botschaft in
Deutschland André Melnik warf ihm vor
Steinmeier habe seit Jahrzehnten ein
Spinnennetz der Kontakte mit Russland
geknüpft
ein Monat später dann ein Telefonat
zwischen dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski und Steinmeier ritation der
Vergangenheit wurden ausgeräumt hieß es
danach
ich habe mit Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier gesprochen und
ihn eingeladen die Ukraine ist offen
vergangene Woche sollte es soweit sein
aber während sein Schweizer Amtskollege
in die Ukraine reiste wurde der Besuch
des Bundespräsidenten aus
Sicherheitsgründen abgesagt heute also
der dritte Anlauf für Steinmeier in der
Ukraine
jahrelang zu russlandfreundlich so der
Vorwurf Eugen kapustin unser User fragt
sich bei YouTube wird das eine
Aufarbeitung der früheren unberechtigten
Nähe zu Russland geben das ist deine
Einschätzung Nicole es ist eine gute
Frage wenn man sich nämlich mal die
Themen anguckt die die einzelnen
Parteien in den vergangenen Jahren für
sich hätten aufarbeiten müssen von denen
sie angekündigt haben sie aufarbeiten zu
wollen und das in Zeiten in denen kein
Krieg quasi vor der Haustür herrschte in
denen keine Energiekrise herrschte in
denen
einen kein Herbst Herrscher von dem wir
noch nicht wissen ob er heiß wird oder
nicht und in denen das vergisst man ja
ab und zu mal nicht auch Pandemie
herrschte ich würde da mal ein dickes
Fragezeichen dran machen ob ich sage das
mal so die Partei also die SPD in diesem
Fall von Frank-Walter Steinmeier
das nicht auch als Gelegenheit sieht
sich nicht ganz so intensiv mit dieser
Frage auseinander zu auseinandersetzen
zu müssen aber ich habe es ja eben schon
mal gesagt
Last klingball kohvorsitzender der SPD
hat diese Fehler vergangene Woche sehr
offen angesprochen also vielleicht tue
ich der SPD damit auch Unrecht
Einschätzung von Nicole Diekmann aus dem
Hauptstadtstudio vielen Dank sehr gerne
und wir können nun sprechen mit unserem
Reporter in der Ukraine mit Sarah Hassan
sardin denn er hat heute morgen am
Bahnhof schon den Bundespräsidenten
gleich empfangen hat heute den ganzen
Tag über natürlich beobachtet daran die
Frage an dich jetzt nach diesem
vollgepackten Tag des Bundespräsidenten
der ja nicht nur in kiewfy ist auch in
den Norden gereist in Nähe von Chemie in
die Nähe der belarussischen Grenze was
war das heute für eine Stimmung im
Verlauf in dieser dieses vollen Tages
den ganzen Programmpunkten vom
Bundespräsidenten wie wurde er da
aufgenommen in der Ukraine
ja heute Morgen war das natürlich auch
sehr früh als er ankam das war 7 Uhr
ukrainische Zeit der Berufsverkehr war
im volle Gange hier in Kiew die Menschen
hatten natürlich dann nicht auf dem
Scheren dass der Bundespräsident jetzt
kam als sie sie darauf angesprochen
haben war es so eine Beiläufigkeit der
mittlerweile sind sie an kann man sagen
Staatsoberhaupt der in ihrer Stadt
gewöhnt es ist nicht mehr so wie am
Anfang in März wo dieses Zeichen der
Solidarität in Kraft gab wo es fast
Euphorie auslöste und dann redethema war
heute war wurde es zur Kenntnis genommen
aber auch weil sich das Verhältnis
natürlich deutlich verbessert hatte weil
der große Ärger der hinter diesen ganzen
Verwicklungen um Stein war um die um
Steinmeiers Ausladung stand war ja die
Waffenlieferung die den Ukrainern zu
wenig war die den Ukrainern zu langsam
vorkamen die Erklärungen waren
ungenügend Aussicht der Ukraine und das
ist jetzt natürlich ganz anders geworden
seitdem die russische Luftwaffe so
radikal die Infrastruktur auch in den
Zentren der Städten angegriffen hat und
dann doch sehr schnell die deutsche
Luftabwehr geliefert wurde die modern
ist und die jetzt auch schon zu
funktionieren das scheint hat sich das
geändert
Tom Frank unser User bei Youtube fragt
sich ob es aber heute nicht auch
kritische Stimmen in Kiew bzw in der
Ukraine gab eben mit der Vergangenheit
von Steinmeier über die wir gerade auch
schon so viel gehört haben
die gibt es auch also
es wird noch dauern bis die Ukraine mit
voller Freude seinen Namen rufen werden
und den Frieden mit der Politik
Steinmeiers der letzten Jahre machen
werden damit wahrscheinlich am ehesten
nie aber ich würde schon sagen dass es
nach vorne geguckt wird und wenn man
allein diese letzten zwei Wochen sich
anschaut
wie unterschiedlich die Gefährdungslage
mittlerweile geworden ist weil die
Luftabwehr in Kiel funktioniert dann ist
das was die Leute sich beschäftigt und
das hat auch was mit der deutschen
Lieferung zu tun und sie wollen jetzt
auch glaube ich nicht nach treten
sondern nach vorne schauen
noch die Frage zum Schluss daran auch
bei Youtube gerade eben reingekommen ist
irgendwas konkretes noch versprochen
worden außer Solidarität Unterstützung
außer Worte außerhalb dieses
Pressetermins fragt sich ein User an die
Userin bei YouTube
ist jetzt was ganz konkretes und es
wirkt wahrscheinlich jetzt fast klein in
dieser Weltpolitik in diesem Krieg
Frank-Walter Steinmeier ist ja der
Norden gefahren dort in dem Ort kurlifka
musste ja auch in den luftschutzkühler
Keller gehen weil es Luftalarm gab und
dort wurde ganz konkret eine
Städtepartnerschaft mit dem Örtchen
Waldkirchen Breisgau festgelegt das ist
was relativ kleines was relativ
konkretes aber daraus kann aber
natürlich der Anfang von vielen
Städtepartnerschaften werden und von
Banden zwischen beiden Ländern und das
muss man auch erwähnen sie haben
winterpakete Mitbürger gebracht die
Delegation von von Steinmeier und die
braucht man da oben in den Gebieten ganz
dringend denn in diesem Bereich wo er
lange das russische Militär die Städte
sind besetzt die Infrastruktur kaputt
und der Winter steht vor der Tür
du sprichst es an genau
Städtepartnerschaften wie auch
vielleicht nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
die zum Zusammenwachsen wieder in Europa
beigetragen haben also vielleicht nur
eine einen kleine konkrete Versprechung
die du uns da geschildert hast aber
vielleicht kann daraus auch was Größeres
werden die Eindrücke live aus Kiew von
Dara Hassan danke dir
danke
und wir können jetzt noch einmal auf die
Gesamtsituation in der Ukraine blicken
und auch dazu gerne eure Fragen und
Kommentare ein paar habe ich schon
gesehen mir auch markiert dazu können
wir jetzt kommen denn in den letzten
beiden Wochen hat Russland die gesamte
Ukraine ja wieder vermehrt angegriffen
mit Raketen mit Drohnen und nicht nur
energiekraftwerke so wie es hieß
getroffen nicht militärische Ziele
sondern eben auch sehr viele zivile
Ziele wurden dabei getroffen Zivilisten
verletzt und getötet und wir blicken nun
auch einmal erst auf einen Beitrag den
wir vorbereitet haben über die
militärische aktuelle Situation in der
Ukraine ein Beitrag von Sven Rieken
Luftalarm in Kiew inzwischen gehört das
für die Menschen in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt fast schon wieder zum Alltag
in dieser Tiefgarage warten André und
die anderen Bewohner im Stadtteil auf
Entwarnungen
wenn kein Luftalarm ist versuchst du
einfach dein normales Leben zu leben
doch plötzlich von einem Moment auf den
anderen musst du hier herunter und all
deine Pläne sind hinfällig
die russischen Raketen galten vermutlich
dem Kraftwerk auf der anderen
Straßenseite sie trafen ein Wohnhaus
dabei versucht Russland ein anderes Bild
zu zeichnen ein SoJ 34 Jagdbomber
irgendwo über der Ukraine angeblich
zielsicher Beweise fehlen
ebenso wie für eine angeblich schmutzige
Bombe an der laut russischem
Verteidigungsministerium die Ukraine
arbeitet
das macht keinen Sinn es gibt keinen
militärischen Sinn für so eine Bombe das
ist nur ein vorwandto mögliche weitere
eskalationsschritte zu gehen
unklar ist auch weiterhin die Situation
rund um den staudammkarovka die Ukraine
warnt vor einer möglichen Sprengung
durch russische Einheiten betroffen wäre
die Stadt herson im Südosten der Ukraine
zeigt sich welche Form der Krieg
inzwischen angenommen hat eine Autobombe
explodiert in Melitopol beide Seiten
geben sich die Schuld militärisch ist
damit nichts erreicht
über die militärische Situation im Land
sprechen wir jetzt mit Ex Nato-General
Egon Rams schönen guten Abend Herr Rams
guten Abend Frau jung
vieles wurde da gerade im Beitrag schon
angesprochen über die aktuelle Situation
insbesondere die Stadt Tressen ist seit
einigen Wochen schwer umkämpft wie
schätzen sie da die aktuelle Lage ein
wie welche Fortschritte macht die
Ukraine tatsächlich wie sieht das da
gerade aus
vielleicht darf ich noch einen Satz
sagen zu dem Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten erschließt eine etwas
unselige Entwicklung ab die ja in den
ist durch diesen Besuch so hoffe ich
abgeräumt ist und damit ein
Schlussstrich gezogen ist und ich meine
das Frank-Walter Steinmeier wie immer
als Bundespräsident dieses richtig
gemacht hat nach dem turbulensten die
wir im April gehabt haben und nach der
Absage vergangene Woche aus
Sicherheitsgründen jetzt zu cascia Song
in dem raumkreis Song haben die Ukrainer
weiterhin Geländegewinne die sich aber
ich sage das mal vorsichtig in einem
Rahmen halten
die festen Übergänge gestürzt
ich hatte gerade ja ja ich hätte gerade
sie nicht mehr gehört aber jetzt höre
ich sie wieder ich glaube die Zuschauer
haben sie aber gehört deswegen lassen
Sie sich bitte nicht
ich lasse mich nicht irritieren also die
Brücke über den hierzu sind zerstört von
daher ist ja auch die Versorgungslage
für die russischen Truppen auf dem
westlichen Ufer des nephros schwierig
die Russen versuchen auch hier ich sage
das mal vorsichtig mit bestimmten
Mitteln Stichwort Evakuierung der
Bevölkerung entsprechenden Druck auf die
Bevölkerung auszuüben die Bevölkerung zu
verunsichern das passt eigentlich in das
Bild was Russland russische Soldaten in
der Ukraine überall verbreiten
einschließlich des Beschusses durch
Drohnen Raketen oder auch
flugzeugangriffe sowohl im westlichen
als auch in anderen Teilen der Ukraine
damit soll die Bevölkerung terrorisiert
werden damit ihr praktisch die Moral
gebrochen wird
die Moral die jetzt für an vielen Orten
noch ungebrochen scheint tatsächlich der
Wiederaufbau ist teilweise in Städten im
gange wo kurz zuvor noch Raketen
runtergegangen sind wir haben viele
Fragen reinbekommen insbesondere zum
Thema Waffenlieferungen die möchte ich
jetzt mal zuerst aufgreifen weil es sich
wirklich gerade bei uns häuft im Chat
und zwar stellt sich hier die Frage ob
auch heute mit dem Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten eben auch das Thema
Panzerlieferungen wieder mehr in den
Fokus rückt Leopard Mader werden da als
Stichwort genannt das kam häufiger die
Frage sehen Sie dafür Zeichen dass ein
Besuch des Bundespräsidenten der ja
nicht der Regierungschef ist aber dazu
führen könnte
nein eigentlich nicht der
Bundespräsident ist der Repräsentant der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der hat als
solcher die Ukraine besucht dennoch wir
kennen keine Details aus den Gesprächen
zwischen dem Präsidenten selenski und
dem Präsidenten Steinmeier kann es
durchaus sein dass selinski dieses Thema
angeschnitten hat denn die Ukraine hat
weiterhin Bedarf an Waffen an
artilleriewaffen an Artillerie Munition
aber natürlich auch wenn Sie das
Momentum der Angriffe der letzten Wochen
erhalten wollen an Kampfpanzer und
Schützenpanzer und dieser Bedarf ist
bisher nicht gedeckt von daher muss man
darüber nachdenken ob man dieses Thema
nicht wieder auch von unserer Seite her
neu aufgreifen sollte oder aufgreifen
muss und wir haben ja versucht dieses
über den Ringtausch zu kompensieren und
der Ringtausch ist eine endliche
Geschichte der wird irgendwann aufhören
weil entsprechende Waffensysteme
sowjetischer Bauart oder russischer
Bauer hat dann auch in unseren
Nato-Partner starten nicht mehr
vorhanden sind das heißt die Frage kommt
immer wieder hoch und sie kommt immer
wieder auf den Tisch
kommen wir noch einmal auf die ja im
Moment verschiedenen Gebiete in der
Ukraine die im Moment mehr im Fokus
stehen im Beitrag auch angesprochen war
der Staudamm kartoffka es kommt eine
Frage von Daniel Wolf hier bei YouTube
der sich fragt ist der Staudamm und die
Region dort so wichtig weil dort der
nord-krim-kanal beginnt können Sie uns
ein bisschen mehr über die Region und
was was dort eine Rolle spielt
also wenn diese dieser Staudamm zerstört
würde dann würde das auch bedeuten dass
die Wasserversorgung der kriminfrage
gestellt wird denn von daher wäre das
eine Sache die den Russen sehr weh tun
würde dennoch wenn der Staudamm
tatsächlich gesprengt würde würde
erstmal eine Flutwelle sich im Tal des
Nepo ergießen und dadurch wäre die
ukrainische Bevölkerung auch zu großen
Teilen schwer betroffen und von daher
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
Ukraine diesen Weg gehen wird zumindest
zur Zeit nicht gehen wird weil sie damit
ihre eigenen Bürger gefährden würde und
das kann Präsident silensky und die
ukrainische Führung nicht wollen
außerdem angesprochenen Beitrag der
Vorwürfe Russlands einer schmutzigen
Bombe dafür gibt es keine Beweise wie
gefährlich sind aber solche Vorwürfe aus
Russland was soll damit bezweckt werden
also mit diesen Vorwürfen will man im
Prinzip die Haltung im Westen
unterminieren die die Ukraine der Westen
der die Ukraine unterstützt und wenn man
einen ein solches Bild aufbaut als Fake
News aufbaut dann könnte es durchaus
sein dass beispielsweise die 143 Staaten
in der vergangenen Woche noch die
Resolution der Vereinten Nationen gegen
Russland aufgrund des Angriffskrieges
und des Krieges gegen die Bevölkerung
vor allen Dingen unterstützt haben dann
praktisch abfallen von der von der
gemeinsamen Entscheidung auch dieses
sind typische Erscheinungen eines
Hybriden Krieges Cyber Warfare und
Information Warfare also
Informationskrieg die von Russland im
Prinzip seit der gesamten Dauer nicht
nur des Kriege sondern auch bereits
vorher nach der Annektierung der krimen
und der Unruhen beziehungsweise
Separatistenbewegung im Don was im Jahr
2014 begonnen haben und das ist nicht zu
Ende und das wird weitergehen und die
Zielrichtung geht in zwei nun dabei das
eine ist einmal die ukrainische
Bevölkerung das andere ist die ich sag
mal Welt draußen und bei der Welt
draußen zielt Russland mit diesen
informationsbedingten Informationskrieg
vor allen Dingen darauf den Westen das
heißt die Europäische Union die NATO zu
spalten und möglicherweise aus der
geschlossenen frontstaaten rauszubrechen
was dann die entsprechende politische
Richtung und Haltung insbesondere der
Europäischen Union sehr deutlich
erschweren würde
ein Informationskrieg das ist es zum
einen das sagen sie richtig ein Krieg
aus der Luft das haben wir in den
letzten zwei Wochen besonders gesehen
und gleichzeitig natürlich schaut man
auch an verschiedene Grenzen auch wieder
mehr an die Grenze im Norden auch der
Bundespräsident ist heute in den Norden
gereist grenzt an Belarus auch dort hat
man in den letzten zwei Wochen
hingeschaut wie der russische
Truppenbewegung war dort zu sehen wie
schätzen Sie die Gefahr dass jetzt
vielleicht Richtung Winter auch wieder
die Gefahr aus dem Norden eben aus
Belarus kommen könnte wie hoch schätzen
Sie die ein
also ich würde das etwas differenzierter
betrachten es geht nicht um eine Gefahr
aus Belarus der Präsident Lukaschenko
verhält sich dort ausgesprochen
geschickt und nimmt nicht eindeutig
Partei 2 verbal eindeutig Partei aber
nicht mit truppenpartei für Russland
erstellt Flughäfen zur Verfügung alles
Raketen möglicherweise auch Drohnen aus
Belarus abschließen abschließen aber er
selber beteiligt sich nicht am
Kriegsgeschehen mit belarussischen
Soldaten und ich glaube er ist ein
kluger Mensch in der Richtung und weiß
dass die Sachen nicht entschieden ist
zumindest noch nicht zugunsten von
Russland entschieden ist und hält sich
glaube ich aus diesem Grunde zurück
wobei ich nicht ausschließen kann das
putin war im durchsetzt das russische
Soldaten dann auch vom Boden
Weißrusslands nach Süden angreifen aber
auch da gilt es vor sich zu sein mit der
Lageeinschätzung und das was da
möglicherweise an Aufstellung von
gemeinsamen Verbänden oder dergleichen
im Augenblick in der in der
medienrummeißer in der Presse
rumgeistert ist für mich noch kein
Beweis dafür das Belarus in dieser Frage
zum Kriegsteilnehmer wird
was passiert ist in den letzten Wochen
ist das Luftabwehr geliefert wurde auch
aus Deutschland ihres Tees da das System
wurde auch vom ukrainischen Präsidenten
eben in seinem Statement angesprochen
die werden von unserem Reporter in der
Ukraine gehört das wirkt wohl auch die
Luftabwehr sei wirksamer in den letzten
Tagen wie würden sie das Einschätzen
gerade im Hinblick auf die
Drohnenangriffe die es eben auch in Kiew
letzten Montag gab ist das im Moment
ausreichend diese Luftabwehr ist die
Forderung nach mehr der Ukraine
besonders gerechtfertigt aktuell wie ist
da ihre Meinung
also man muss die gesamte Palette sehen
die bisher an Flugabwehrwaffen oder
flugabwehrmitteln an die Ukraine
geliefert worden ist da gehört mit die
fliegerfäuste
red-eier und Stinger die ursprünglich
bereits zu Anfang oder relativ früh
während des Krieges geliefert worden
sind da gehört der Flakpanzer Gebhardt
mit dazu und da gehört jetzt ihres Tee
mit dazu ihre ST ist eines der
modernsten Systeme die wir zurzeit haben
und es wäre gut wenn vor allen Dingen
zur flächendeckenden fluchabwehr mehr
Systeme Ihr System möglichst bald an die
Ukraine geliefert werden können nach
meinem Kenntnisstand ist bisher ein
System da drei weitere Systeme sollen
folgen das waren Systeme die
ursprünglich mal für Ägypten produziert
worden war waren und es gibt noch eine
zweite Variante ihres tslm das wäre ein
System mit einer noch größeren
Reichweite und wenn die deutsche
Industrie und das ist ein deutsches
Produkt in der Lage wäre diese Systeme
sehr schnell zu produzieren und dann
auch entsprechend die zus der
Bundesregierung erfolgt diese an die
Ukraine abzugeben so wäre das für die
Ukraine sehr hilfreich aber ich möchte
noch mal daran erinnern dass auch die
Amerikaner mittlerweile in den letzten
Entscheidungen bekannt gegeben haben
dass Sie die Absicht haben
Flugabwehrsysteme an die Ukraine zu
liefern dass die sind nach meinem
Kenntnisstand bisher nicht eingetroffen
aber wenn diese dazu kommen kann es für
die Ukraine eine weitere Verbesserung
geben und es muss das Ziel der Ukraine
sein sowohl gegen Drohnen als auch
Raketen und Flugzeuge eine
funktionsfähige Flugabwehr nach
Möglichkeit über dem ganzen Land
aufzubauen von daher dürfte jede Hilfe
in dieser Richtung in der Ukraine sehr
willkommen sein
dann schauen wir noch einmal auch ein
bisschen in die Zukunft Richtung Ende
der Sendung und zwar gab es ja auch ein
Internet internationale Konferenz in
Berlin heute wo es auch eben um wieder
Aufbauhilfen für die Ukraine geht wir
haben eine Frage bei Facebook von Sven
Odenthal der sich fragt wie könnte ein
Marshallplan für die Ukraine aussehen
und würde selenski eine Integration
eines nach Putin Russlands in ein
westliches Bündnis überhaupt begrüßen
also ich fange mal mit dem zweiten Teil
der Frage an weil das eine Sache ist die
kann man zurzeit nicht beurteilen das
ist selbst ein Nachwuchs in Russland ist
für uns ja heute schwer einzuschätzen
und das heißt ja nicht wenn Putin nicht
mehr da ist als Präsident als russischer
Präsident dass sich irgendjemand hinter
ihm herkommt der im Prinzip dieselbe
Politik betreibt das ist eine Sache die
ist für mich im Augenblick
unvorhersehbar und von daher sollte man
in diesem Bereich nicht anfangen zu
spekulieren das muss die Zeit bringen
mit dem anderen Teil mit dem anderen
Teil der Frage es ist schwierig die
Situation in diesem Bereich entsprechend
so zu beurteilen dass man tatsächlich
auch auf bestimmte Ergebnisse rechnen
kann die hier tatsächlich Veränderungen
bringen ich möchte einen Finger möchte
ich warnend heben und zwar in der
Richtung dass ich sage wir sollten nicht
von unserer Seite her auf Verhandlungen
drängen oder über Verhandlungen
entscheiden wollen oder Verhandlungen
anregen sei es mit Putin selber oder sei
es in einer nach putin-zeit einfach aus
dem Grunde ist eine Sache ist die die
Ukraine der ukrainische Präsident das
ukrainische Parlament und das
ukrainische Volk entscheiden müssen auf
welcher Basis dann irgendwann
Verhandlungen geführt werden die dann zu
einem Frieden führen können das bringt
mich noch mal zurück auf diese auf diese
Steinmeier auf diese Steinmeier
Vorschlag den wir in den 2000er Jahren
gehabt haben oder nach dem nach Minz 2
gehabt haben wo es ja darum ging das
gesagt worden war das praktisch der Don
Bass mehr oder weniger ausgeklammert
werden sollte ein Sonderstatus bekommen
konnte bekommen sollte und die Krim im
Prinzip nicht Gegenstand irgendwelcher
Gespräche oder der Verhandlung gewesen
wäre
silensky ist glaube ich damals als ihr
junger Präsident hat er dem zugestimmt
weil Putin bei Minz 2 sehr darauf
gedrängt hat es wäre keine Lösung
geworden
ja und eine Frage die da vielleicht auch
noch mal zu stellen ist die ja die
Forderung nach diplomatischen
Verhandlungen wird auch immer wieder
laut zuletzt SPD-Fraktionschef Rolf
Mütze nicht ist dafür die diplomatischen
Anstrengung zu verstärken es gelte eine
Balance zwischen dem
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine und
diplomatischen Initiativen herzustellen
das sagte er bei uns im ZDF sie haben es
eben gerade angesprochen dass man im
Prinzip da die Ukraine wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe natürlich
lassen muss bzw meine Frage ist
eigentlich wie schätzen Sie das ein
diplomatische Verhandlungen solche
Forderungen solche rufe ist das
gerechtfertigt sollten die überhaupt
kommen in Anbetracht natürlich der Lage
in der sich die Ukraine immer noch
befindet und in dem in dem Stadium in
dem sich dieser Krieg befindet dieser
russische Angriffskrieg
sie hatten vorhin in ihrem Beitrag
angesprochen dass Lars Klingbeil gesagt
hat dass die SPD noch mal prüfen müsse
ob sie in der Vergangenheit mit Blick
auf die Russlandpolitik Fehler gemacht
hat sie sollte das möglicherweise nicht
Überblick auf die Vergangenheit
überprüfen sondern auch auf die aktuelle
Situation wir sollten von unserer Seite
her in dieser Richtung keine Vorschläge
machen die letztendlich die Ukraine in
eine bestimmte Ecke setzen nämlich dass
sie nicht verhandlungswillig ist oder
dergleichen mehr Verhandlungen brauchen
Voraussetzungen die dann entsprechend
erfüllt werden sollen und welche
Voraussetzung das sind darüber
entscheidet die Ukraine und sonst
niemand die Diplomatie ist nicht aus dem
Geschäft es wird miteinander gesprochen
es gibt Verbindung zwischen Russland und
Amerika es gibt Verbindungen zwischen
Russland und der NATO von daher finden
Gespräche weiter statt wie
beispielsweise in den letzten Tagen
zwischen dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister und dem
amerikanischen Verteidigungsminister nur
es zeigt sich bei diesen Gesprächen dass
sie im Augenblick nicht sehr produktiv
Bild weil offensichtlich Russland sich
immer noch erhofft dass es die vier
annektierten zu Unrecht annektierten
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten Oblaste
vielleicht ganz einnehmen kann und dann
ganz behalten kann und als russisches
Territorium bezeichnen kann man musste
aber einfach feststellen dass von
russischer Seite Rechtsgrundlagen
verändert worden sind in einer Form die
stets zum Nachteil der Ukraine sind und
dass das nicht akzeptabel ist und nicht
akzeptabel wird
sagt ex-nato-general Egon Rams der auch
heute uns wieder mit seiner Analyse
versorgt hat vielen Dank dafür heranz
gerne
herzlichen Dank
an einem Tag an dem der Bundespräsident
der deutsche Bundespräsident Frank
Walter Steinmeier zu Gast in der Ukraine
war zur Stunde vermutlich wieder auf dem
Rückweg wir hoffen wir konnten einige
von euren Fragen dazu beantworten wir
haben zum Schluss jetzt auch noch einmal
ein paar letzte Bilder dieses Treffens
was jetzt nach acht Monaten endlich
stattfand zwischen dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski und dem deutschen
Bundespräsidenten Frank-Walter
Steinmeier die wir euch jetzt zum Ende
noch mal zeigen können ein Handschlag
den es dort zum Ende gab ein Treffen was
lange auf sich warten ließ und was nun
also stattgefunden hat Steinmeier hat
noch am Ende zu selensky gesagt dass er
sein Land in beeindruckender Art und
Weise führt und dass er dafür großen
Respekt habe dass die Worte zum Schluss
des Bundespräsidenten an diesem Tag und
wir freuen uns natürlich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder in unserer
Sendung dabei seid und genauso viel
fragt wie heute und wir versuchen so
viel fragen wie möglich für euch zu
beantworten
danke bis dahin und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss